in this segment we will derive a formula
for the variance of the geometric PMF
the argument will be very much similar
to the argument that we use to derive
the expected value of the geometric PMF
and it relies on the memorylessness
properties of geometric random variables
so let X be a geometric random variable
with some parameter P the way to think
about X is like the number of coin flips
that it takes until we obtain heads for
the first time where P is the
probability of heads at each toss recall
now the memorylessness property if I
tell you that X is bigger than 1 which
means that the first trial was a failure
we obtained tails giving that event the
remaining number of tosses has the same
geometric PMF as if we were just
starting at this time so it has the same
geometric PMF as the unconditional PMF
of X and this is the property that we
exploited in order to find the expected
value of x now let us take this
observation and add one to the random
variables involved and turned this
statement to the following version the
conditional PMF of X which is this
random variable plus 1 is the same as
the unconditional PMF of this random
variable plus 1 so it's the same
statement as before except that we added
1 1 consequence of the memorylessness
that we have already seen and exploited
is that the expected value of x in the
conditional universe where the first
coin flip was wasted is equal to 1
that's the wasted coin flip plus how
long you expect to have to flip the coin
until you obtain heads for the first
time starting from the second flip since
the conditional distribution of X in
this universe is the same as the
unconditional distribution of this
random variable it means that the
corresponding expected value in this
universe is going to be equal to the
expected value of this random variable
which is 1 plus
expected value of X and buy exactly the
same argument the random variable x
squared has the same distribution in the
conditional universe as the random
variable X plus 1 squared in the
unconditional universe so since X in the
conditional universe has the same
distribution as X plus 1 it means that X
square in the conditional universe has
the same distribution as X plus 1
squared in the unconditional universe so
now let us take those facts and use a
divide and conquer method to calculate
the expected value of x squared we will
use exactly the same method that we we
used in order to calculate the expected
value we separate into two scenarios in
one scenario X is equal to 1 and then we
have the expected value of x squared
given that X is equal to 1 and then we
have another scenario the scenario that
X is bigger than 1 and then we have the
expected value of x squared
even that X is bigger than 1 so this is
just the total expectation theorem now
let us calculate terms the probability
that the first toss results in success
that X is equal to 1 this is P and if X
is equal to 1 then the value of x
squared is also equal to 1 and then
there is probability 1 minus P that the
first trial was not a success so we get
to continue we have this conditional
expectation here but it is equal to this
unconditional expectation up there and
now let us expand the terms in this
quadratic and write this as expected
value of x squared plus twice the
expected value of x plus 1 now we know
what this expected value here is the
expected value of a geometric is just 1
over P
and what we're left with is an equation
that involves a single unknown namely
this quantity is the unknown and we can
solve this linear equation for this
unknown we carry out some algebra which
is not so interesting by itself and
after we carry out the algebra what we
obtain is that the expected value of x
squared is equal to 2 over P squared
minus 1 over P and then we use the
formula that the variance of the run of
a random variable is equal to the
expected value of the square of that
random variable minus the square of the
expected value we already know what that
expected value is we found the expected
value of the square and putting all that
together we obtain a final answer and
this is the expression for the variance
of a geometric random variable it goes
without saying that for this calculation
to make sense we need to assume that the
parameter that we're dealing with is
positive